so meine Damen und Herren und jetzt ist
es passiert jetzt ist es amtlich die
Ampel ist endgültig mutiert von der
selbst ernannten fortschrittskoalition
zur wir bleiben nur noch wegen Krieg
zusammen Koalition ja da ist wirklich
gar keine Liebe mehr Freunde gar keine
ja sie schicken einander wütende Briefe
oder beleidigen sich in Interviews ja
wie so eine assi-familie halten mit
leider sehr konkreten Folgen für uns die
Süddeutsche kommt aktuell auf 30
Vorhaben bei denen sich die ampelpartner
gegenseitig blockieren Stillstand statt
Fortschritt bestes Beispiel die
Beschleunigung von
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen weil die FDP im
Gegensatz zu den Grünen will das auch
Autobahn schneller gebaut werden klingen
Ampel Pressekonferenzen dazu inzwischen
so wie positioniert sich dann aktuell
das Verkehrs und das Umweltministerium
dazu wann ist damit eine Einigung zu
rechnen
entschuldigen sie bitte ich war jetzt
gerade mit meiner Aufmerksamkeit nicht
bei Ihrer Frage könnten sie netterweise
noch mal das Stichwort geben na klar es
geht um das
planungsbeschleunigungsverfahren Wann
kann damit einem Kompromiss gerechnet
werden wie stehen da Umweltministerium
und Verkehrsministerium
aktuellen Stand für sie ja gut das war
nicht geweckt haben würde ich sagen das
hat sich ja voll gelohnt einer pennt
einer schweigt FDP und Grüne machen fast
nur noch Klientelpolitik und das ist
doch kein Wunder dass die Ampel in
Umfragen keine Mehrheit mehr hat okay
Linden als Vorteil als Finanzminister
ist natürlich er hat den Schlüssel zur
Kasse und wenn die Grünen mehr Geld für
ihre Projekte wollen dann sagt er in der
Rolle der schwäbischen Hausfrau mir gäbe
nix
während seinen Kampf von Kubicki Sachen
verknüpft die gar nicht zusammenhängen
die Zeit ist
etwa Vize kubiki
uns keinen Straßenbau mehr gäbe es auch
keine Stromleitung da könne sich der
Robert gehackt legen
und Robert so deine Mutter kann sich
gehackt legen Kubicki absoluter
Kindergarten Lindner und Habeck ist kein
Witz siezen sich neuerdings wieder die
sitzen sich und der gehacktliegende
robert hat dem Christian in einem Brief
mitgeteilt dass seine grünen die
Eckpunkte für den nächsten Haushalt
nicht mehr akzeptieren er achte im
Prinzip schon irgendwie die
Schuldenbremse aber man könnte ja zum
Beispiel auch mal Steuern erhöhen
worauf Lindner nach kurzem Herzkasper
mit einem extrem sarkastischen schreiben
geantwortet hat hier Welt explosiv meine
Damen und Herren die Briefe die danach
zwischen den beiden hin und her gegangen
sind erst hat der Harbeck an Lindner
geschrieben lieber Mann von der einen
Welt Moderatorin hier dein selfie zurück
so gefällt mir besser
pS Ich habe deinen Angeber Porsche beim
Carsharing angemeldet lach Smiley darauf
schreibt Lindner
ey Kinderbuchautor wir haben dein
Lastenfahrrad wenn du noch einmal
Tempolimit sagst 30 in die Speichen
einzeln raus PS der Tofu-Burger den ich
neulich mitgebracht habe war billig Hack
vom Netto haha
es ist nur noch lächerlich das sind doch
erwachsene Männer die sollen sich
gefälligst mal in einen Tisch setzen
wenn es nur der von Putin ist
irgendwer muss da endlich mal ein Ampel
Machtwort sprechen da Kanzler zum
Beispiel geht aber nicht denn der
Kanzler hat andere wichtige Termine bei
denen er rhetorisch brilliert
Deutschland baut unverändern auf
Handwerk auf das ist ganz ganz wichtig
und natürlich gilt das gerade wenn es um
so traditionelle Lebensmittel geht wie
das Brot in ganz begeistert davon dass
das unverändert für unser Leben eine
Rolle spielt
Brot spielt in unserem Leben unverändert
eine Rolle
mutiger Satz von einem der so wenig
gebacken kriegt sage ich mal
die Ampel muss endlich aus dem Mürbeteig
kommen denn nicht nur die Bundeswehr
braucht ständig mehr Geld das sind ja
auch noch ein paar andere Krisen ich
sage nur Klimawandel ja genau das Thema
auf das keiner mehr Bock hat was dem
Klimawandel aber herzlich egal ist der
fortschrittmonitor Energiewende hat
genau deswegen gerade erst die Ampel
abgewaschen weil es bei den Erneuerbaren
immer noch viel zu langsam geht genau
wie beim Ausbau der Speichertechnik und
der Netze das einzige was schnell kommt
sind Terminals für Flüssiggas und wir
wundern uns dass die Aktivisten von der
letzten Generation frei drehen
wenn auch mit Aktionen die immer
rätselhafter werden wie am Dienstag vor
dem Kanzleramt sie sägt und sägt bis der
Baum fällt und zwar mit einer klaren
Botschaft wir Regierung fällt gerade an
unser allererst das kann nicht sein ja
dieses Wortspiel fand ich Achtung
unsäglich
Bäume fällen für die Umwelt als nächstes
schlagen sie wahrscheinlich Robbenbabys
tot um gegen Pelze zu protestieren ah ja
und fleißig geklebt wird natürlich auch
weiter logisch am liebsten im
Berufsverkehr was bei den direkt
Betroffenen offenbar auf immer weniger
Verständnis stößt mit Tendenz zur
Selbstjustiz
[Musik]
das reicht sie bleiben jetzt
rüber jetzt
wenn Realschullehrer durchdrehen
und bei allem Verständnis für Frust im
Verkehr es kann aber auch nicht sein
dass ich jetzt irgendwelche Spießer
ungefragt zu hilfsheriffs ernennen ich
glaube wir sollten da dringend die
Führerscheinprüfung anpassen diesen
neuen Realitäten Beispiel sie nähern
sich an der Kreuzung an der sich ein
Klima Kleber festgepappt hat was jetzt
ah ich warte bis ich die Situation
entspannt und lasse die aufgestaute Wut
zu Hause an meiner Familie aus B ich
Filme die anderen Autofahrer aber ihren
Wutausbrüchen und kassiere 50 € als Bild
Leserreporter oder C ich fahre dem Klima
Terroristen über den Fuß beachte dabei
aber die zulässige Höchstgeschwindigkeit
von 50 km/h innerhalb geschlossener
Ortschaften komm wir lösen es direkt mal
auf
sind sie bescheuert ja Kinder das war
eine rhetorische Frage
über Füße fahren ist übrigens auch
strafbar hoffe ich zumindest
Straftaten sind in einer Demokratie
natürlich nie wirklich legitim selbst
wenn die Ampel gegen ihre eigenen
klimagesätze verstößt was sie tut
rechtzeitig das keine Gesetzesbrüche
durch Aktivisten sag mal die ganze der
Zweck heiligt die Mitte Logik ist
brandgefährlich weil durch die Tür
können dann später auch andere gehen ja
liebe Zuschauer vielleicht haben sie das
noch gar nicht mitbekommen aber nächsten
Mittwoch endet eine der allerletzten
corona-maßnahmen die maskenpflicht für
Patienten und Personal in medizinischen
Einrichtung Corona ist auf
Abschiedstournee und das wäre eine gute
Gelegenheit mal zu fragen was wir bei
der nächsten Pandemie und die kommt
besser machen müssen weil wir aber immer
noch Deutsche sind kommen wir
stattdessen zu unserer Liebling wer ist
hier alles Schuld ja also wem kann man
im Nachhinein für was die Schuld geben
da fällt mir ein Karl Lauterbach ist
diese Woche 60 geworden
herzlichen Glückwunsch herzlichen
Glückwunsch ja der karl hat sie aber
nicht groß gefeiert wirklich nur im
allerersten Kreis aber war trotzdem
schöner Abend
was man so hört ich war ja nicht
eingeladen ansonsten zieht Lauterbach
weiter durch die Talkshows und klingt
dabei neuerdings fast als wer unter die
Querdenker gegangen es gab natürlich
Dinge die überzogen waren das war im
Nachhinein ein Fehler also einen Fehler
war eben lange Schuhe stehe zum
Nachhinein betrachtet ein Fehler das war
ein riesen Fehler war wahrscheinlich ein
Fehler es hat Fehler gegeben das war auf
jeden Fall ja das war ein Fehler selbst
unsere Kinder lachen schon darüber ja
schön wärs schön wär's äh die Kinder
haben gar keine Zeit zu lachen die
müssen in der Schule Wissen aus dem
Corona ja nachholen Karl Lauterbach muss
man sagen gibt wenigstens Fehler zu
wenn auch hauptsächlich die von Jens
Spahn aber immerhin immerhin die
flächendeckende Schließung von Schulen
und Kitas hätte es nie geben dürfen
Punkt
nicht nur wegen der psychologischen
Folgen ganz aktuelle Studien sagen die
Schülerinnen und Schüler haben da 35 %
des Lernfortschritts eines normalen
Schuljahres verloren in Mathematik war
das Defizit stärker als beim lesen was
die Autoren damit erklären dass Eltern
und Kinder schon seit frühesten
Kindertagen daran gewöhnt sind zu Hause
gemeinsam zu lesen aber nicht
Mathematikaufgaben zu bearbeiten nein
hör doch auf
na soll Papa dir den Grüffelo vorlesen
oder lieber die binomischen Formeln
binomische Formeln
manche Politiker schieben das mit den
Schulen jetzt im Nachhinein auf
Virologen also auf die Wissenschaft
dabei hat zum Beispiel der Drosten gar
nicht für flächendeckende Schließung
plädiert das haben dann einzelne
Ministerpräsidenten entschieden die hier
nicht namentlich genannt werden soll und
mehrere bei einem Publikum heute hallo
Ministerpräsidenten übrigens alle ihre
eigenen beraterstäbe haben warum auch
immer Berater Stäbe ohne Ende Vorschlag
für die nächste Pandemie ein zentrales
Berater Gremium fertig außerdem sollten
Experten ehrlich und in Ruhe bewerten
welche corona-maßnahmen richtig waren
und welche totaler Quatsch und genau das
fordert auch der scheidende Präsident
des das Robert Koch-Instituts Lothar
Matthias Mutter wieder Verzeihung guten
Morgen ist sehr früh ja komm kleiner
kleiner Versprecher der ex-rki-chef
heißt natürlich Stefan Effenberg das
wissen wir ja es gab natürlich viele
sehr sinnlose Maßnahmen wie das
Absperren von Spielplätzen oder das
berühmte verweilverbot beim
Spazierengehen dass man auf bayerischen
Parkbänken keine Bücher lesen durfte
aber über andere Feder wird eben heute
zu wenig geredet warum schaffen es zum
Beispiel die Engländer mit einem Panel
in Echtzeit zu verfolgen was Corona
macht inklusive Maßnahmen Evaluierung
wir aber nicht warum nicht eine klar
manches ist bei uns auch ganz gut
gelaufen meins zum Beispiel Sie haben
richtig gehört unser liebes altes Mainz
ist dankbariontech plötzlich das
reichste provinzkraft der Welt so
derartig reicht die haben jetzt sogar
das Ortsschild geändert
meins ist heute die einzige Stadt in der
Obdachlose nur Kreditkarten akzeptiert
in der Mensa fast nach werfen sie nur
noch Rolex Uhren und thermomixe meins
hat den reichsten Lokalsender der Welt
sogar die Mainzelmännchen sind so
fucking Reich der Depp hat sich letzte
Woche tot geguckt
ja aber das wirklich nur als kleine
Randnotiz für mein sleeves ganz gut so
Corona was lernen wir daraus leider weiß
man ja nicht wann die nächste Pandemie
kommt da gibt es noch keinen Termin
deswegen wäre es klug unser
Gesundheitssystem jetzt dafür fit zu
machen nach der Zoonose ist vor der Zone
trotzdem stellt in der Politik achten
Sie mal drauf kaum einer ernsthaft die
Massentierhaltung in Frage kaum einer
fakt ist alle verheerenden solchen der
letzten Jahrzehnte sind vom Tier auf den
Menschen übergegangen fast alle
Lerneffekt Zero herzlich Willkommen zu
Germany's next topvirus bei Dennis
knossalla
[Musik]
Leute forget Corona Corona ist so
twenty2 ich sag mal wer heute noch Profi
kriegt der trägt auch Plateauschuhe zum
Balenciaga
[Gelächter]
kriegt man gar nicht nee sie können
alles tragen sie immer scheiße aus
wir suchen die neue Tierseuche zu Rose
statt tote Hose aktuell gibt es 10.000
Erreger im Tierreich die das Zeug haben
auf den Menschen überzuspringen aber nur
einer wird Germany's next topvirus und
hier kommt unser neuer Kandidat
hallo
hallo ich bin ein influencervirus mein
Name ist H5N1 Spitzname Vogelgrippe
nicht verwechseln mit der vögel-grippe
das sind die affenporten
Kleider Scherz wenn ihr nichts gegen das
affenpockenvirus ganz lieber Kollege
Humor ich mag deinen Style ja du erzähl
doch mal von dir wo siehst du dich in 5
Jahren
was mit Menschen machen das wäre voll
mein Traum im Moment sind halt
hauptsächlich Vögel Möwen Schwäne oder
Hühner in engen lege Batterien deswegen
gucke ich immer Heidi Klum weil die auch
gern dumme Hühner quält
[Gelächter]
moment mal moment mal der Hühner Heini
ist überhaupt nicht lustig Varianten von
H5 N1 haben längst den Sprung auf
Säugetiere geschafft doch wie gelingt es
dem an Vögel angepassten Erreger auch
Seehunde zu gefallen
wenn sich Viren in einem neuen wird
vermehren können wird eine Lawine
ausgelöst
ja und dann muss einem Löwe direkt ins
Auge Scheiße also mal ehrlich wie oft
passiert das denn wir könnten sie mir im
Flug aus fünf Metern Höhe genau ins Auge
das war doch nur ein Beispiel
über Seehunde Füchse oder Katzen kann
das Virus bei uns landen über Vögel ist
das ja vereinzelt schon passiert H5 N1
hat von allen Viren das größte
pandemie-potenzial das habe ich
gegoogelt ich meine wir können ja
schlecht alle Vögel impfen das stimmt
fangen die mal viele von denen können
fliegen ich behaupte Vögel sind sogar
noch schwerer zu impfen als Ostdeutsche
mein Gott bis jetzt ist nur eine
Handvoll Leute an Vogelgrippe gestorben
das Virus übt ja noch wie gut sind wir
denn vorbereitet wenn die Übung dann
ernst wird sind wir mit Medikamenten
Impfstoffen gewappnet
also so könnte ich sagen grundsätzlich
nein
ja gut das ist natürlich grundsätzlich
blöd ja vorbereiten müsste man sich
schon macht ihr nie deswegen bin ich ja
so ein Homosapiens Fan die besten wird's
jeder so wunderbar schlecht ständig
Demos gegen Bill Gates aber nie gegen
Massentierhaltung danke dafür nicht
experten sagen die Frage ist nicht ob
eine mutierte Vogelgrippe für uns
gefährlich wird sondern nur wann ach
jetzt hör mal auf zu heulen welche
wirklich wenn du Angst hast wo vögeln
dann bleib drinnen da kann ja nichts
passieren alles Weichei
och nö ich liebe den Mann Dennis
knossalla
[Applaus]
Dennis
so meine Damen und Herren zu den zu den
besonders gekniffenen Gruppen der
corona-jahre gehören natürlich auch die
Studierenden und dabei bleibt es im
Wesentlichen denn die warten immer noch
auf die 200 € energiegeld und
Inflationsausgleich die ihn letztes Jahr
von der Ampel versprochen wurden aber
Hosianna jetzt kommt die Kohle wohl also
nicht jetzt aber bald
angeblich vielleicht bestimmt
20 Jahren eingeschrieben an der Fernuni
Hagen
kann sein Glück kaum fassen
the secret live of the crazy rich heute
deutsche Studenten
Leute die Bildungsministerin hat uns 200
Euro versprochen wie geil ist das denn
mega geil ja klar einfach weil wir
jungen Leute und Frau stark Watzinger
wir sind Klaus weil uns die jungen
Menschen wichtig sind ja man ich habe
schon Überbrückungskredit aufgenommen
damit ich jetzt schon die gelddusche
aufdrehen kann Fernuni Hagen kiss me S
habe ich von der Kohle erstmal neu
eingekleidet
das ist jetzt der neueste Teil da bist
du der König vom Audi max 200 € machen
es möglich oder so viel mehr
200 €, die steigende Kosten abfedern 200
€, die das Leben ein Stück leichter
machen 200 €, die ein Stück mehr
Freiheit bringen ja klar 200 € und neues
Leben startet natürlich aber was mache
ich mit dem Rest vom Geld
kaufe ich mir ein Auto oder lege ich sie
an oder studiere ich Ethnologie und hol
mir eine neue Hängematte
klar die Rentner haben 300 Euro gekriegt
aber die können halt auch
verantwortungsvoller mit dem Geld
umgehen und die haben die Parteien ja
auch schon viel häufiger gewählt nur
eine winzige Rückfrage hätte ich noch
also jetzt gar nicht als Kritik gemeint
aber wann kommt die Kohle endlich
angekündigt war ja im September 22 und
im Dezember hieß es ist das Tool ist
schon in Arbeit in der Konzeption damit
eben Anfang nächsten Jahres die Gelder
auch bei den jungen Menschen ankommen
noch in diesem Winter
ist nächsten Dienstag vorbei
also die meinten doch den deutschen
Winter oder die Einmalzahlung von 200 €
für alle Studierenden und für
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler sie ist
auf der Zielgeraden das ist die nächste
Zielgerade der Welt dass die einzige
Ziele gerade jemand vom Weltraum
aussehen kann okay sagen wir der Winter
ist dann zu Ende wenn die 200 € da sind
und wenn es august wird klar das ist
nicht so leicht sowas für dreieinhalb
Millionen Studie zu organisieren denn
IBAN man ich hat aber das muss man ja
eigentlich vorher egal jetzt geht es ab
einfach anmelden bei kein Scheiß WWW
Punkt Einmalzahlung 200.de und Du bist
dabei
also wenn du ein bundes-id Konto hast
das haben jetzt mehr als drei Millionen
Studierende nicht aber ja im Prinzip ist
die ganze Sache wie gesagt sie ist auf
der Zielgeraden aber sowas von es ist
echt nur noch eine Frage von Monaten
ehrlich inzwischen tut mir diese
überforderte Regierung so leid ich
überlege schon den aus Mitleid meine 200
€ zurück zu überweisen ja ich will es
alleine bis zum zweiten Porsche schaffen
hier die IBAN der Bundeskasse macht mit
ja komm die brauchen das Geld
Verwendungszweck Demokratie ist keine
Einbahnstraße danke
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehirn ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig